[Musik]
dieser film handelt davon dass sich der
mensch im allgemeinen dinge einbrockt
die ihm dann im besonderen auf dem magen
liegen wurde wie diese geschichte zeigt
unter dem boden und zwar für jemand es
mag vordergründig um radioaktivität
gehen und die machtlosigkeit von bürgern
um die pläne der mächtigen
vor allem aber darum dass es in einer
kompliziert gewordenen welt keine
einfachen lösungen mehr gibt
[Musik]
wohl stimmen genau das muss mit ihnen im
standort oberflächen art von einlagen
was heißt das konkret wie gesetzt
weiterer malus wir stellen sie sich also
zuerst einmal wird mega baustelle bei
also also im stil von den erdball
stellen wird die ganze roos aber das
wird die patientin schon mal klappen und
projekt und ausstellte und mit bunten
dafür gegen die auf jeden fall das
klassische für alle zeiten
[Musik]
was er für das übelste aller übel hält
ist für ihn eine optimale lösung
was sie als eine notwendigkeit anschaut
hätte sie wiederum schon gar nicht erst
angefangen
seit 48 jahren produziert die schweiz
energie in kernkraftanlagen damals war
dass die zukunft seither stehen wir vor
der ungelösten frage was wir mit
radioaktiven abfällen tun sollen
fast ebenso lange sucht die nationale
genossenschaft für die lagerung
radioaktiver abfälle nagra nach
geeigneten standorten zum beispiel würde
sie den atommüll gerne unter den ecken
des bauern julia sie entsorgen
die geologische beschaffenheit sei hier
im zürcher weinland besonders günstig
naja bis 20.000 passieren
[Musik]
das beruhigt
da
[Musik]
aber wir haben
weiter
angaben breiten in ordnung
ereignisreich
ich war einer davon
dort
ging es weiter
vorher macht was sie
jörg haase ist bauer im aatal ihn trifft
es besonders hart
sein vater hatte den hof in den 80er
jahren gebaut
nur wenige jahre später fuhr die nagra
mit den bohrmaschinen auf unserer seite
her zurück ganze geschichte naja wenn ja
darf ist das bisher in teheran iran
irgendwer störte da zusammen mit seiner
frau rachel sammelt julia sie alle
unterlagen und artikel zum thema er
stößt sich daran dass die nagra seiner
meinung nach das projekt viel zu harmlos
darstelle
er selbst hatte jedoch vor mir haben
meine repository mir worauf ich dass der
bevölkerung sagt das ist klar das ist
mein ideales sein
die deutsche variante version dar an
bord einer us-maschine die fabrik die
produzierten wie oft er kein ertrag ab
oder produziert für diese gesellschaft
irgendwie sondern nur den abfall
entsorgen und dass man dauer hektar
rallyes landoberfläche erlag
das rät jetzt nun mal einfach vom vor
dem denn denn ich das falsche und
begriff weiß nicht was ich meine
emotionale hatte die erste chance
auflegte 14 tage verloren und mexiko
vorstellen da wächst oder das dann
einmal gemacht
wenigstens haben kann man sagen das
menschenmögliche probieren hatte stempel
ich nicht so kommt dem ressort eine
schluss sein
und ich will einfach jetzt sein neuestes
filmprojekt abonnieren
es wäre dann keine option um sie in
marthalen leben 1800 menschen dar und
stopps hängen ein paar plakate gegen das
geplante endlager bei abstimmungen
setzten sich die atomfreundlichen
stimmen aber regelmäßig glücklich so
auch im november 2016 hat sich fast 60
prozent gegen den sofortigen
atomausstieg aussprachen
die gemeindepräsidentin will deshalb
aber nicht von einem graben in der
bevölkerung sprechen also user meint
hetze gegen ausländer befürworter und im
moment ist sehr ruhig will es sich
einfach irgendwie ein zweiter weg für
christen bevölkerung ist das
grundsätzliche problem mit dem thema das
ist eigentlich sehr ist langfristig ist
es wahrscheinlich frühestens in 40
jahren glaube den effektiv
der bundesrat entscheidet ihr euch sandy
2018 valley standard dass sie der
dritten etappe wieder klar werden und es
in 40 oder 50 wird denn in 40 kämpfen
felslabor etwas den bauer wird und 50
würde denn die erste klage statt
windkanal fast gefühl dass sowie die
ältere bevölkerung wird sich damit
befassen
die junge die lage ganz anders da wir in
würenlingen im kanton aargau nahe der
deutschen grenze steht gut bewacht und
gesichert das zwilag in diesem
zwischenlager befinden sich die
radioaktiven abfälle die sich in den
letzten jahren angesammelt haben
[Musik]
hier treffe ich markus fritschi rechts
im bild ein direktionsmitglied der nagra
zusammen mit roland keller den medien
verantwortlich in das zwilag gewährt er
einen einblick ins innerste dieser
anlage
hinter der kirche sehr schön puppe
schwindels jetzt genau die sind jetzt da
in der lagerhalle für die transport- und
lagerbehälter was sieht auch sind sind
behälter wo hochaktive abfälle gelagert
sind dass dadurch ein behälter mit
verbrauchte brennelemente aus dem
betrieb hosen kernkraftwerk auf tyler
sieht in sogenannten castor behälter
werde behälter wusste widerruf arbeite
ich dann einmal auch größere der
fabrikneues amerikanischen hüterin der
schaut sich höhe der behälter auf der
anderen seite da ich bereits warm will
die abfahrt produziert wärme und wenn
man da langt dann spürt man die wärme
das ist für dich das so uhr
körpertemperatur und was sie da gesehen
sinkt rippe wo dazu führen dass die
wärme entsprechen gut abgeführt wird
aber da sind sie jetzt bedenkenlos und
langen dass die behälter sind uns da
völlig kontamination frau bedanken los
man sieht jetzt nützen bereits zwei
tagen ab dass meine behälter kein bürger
man keine allzu langen haare ab nach
problemlos dazu und spürt einfach da die
zerfalls wärme
hochaktive brennelemente in 120
behältern warten hier auf ihre
unterirdische bestimmung
dort sollen sie dann mehrere zehntausend
jahre lang zeit haben um abzukühlen
[Musik]
es ist ja eigentlich verständlich
widerstand der behälter der
erdoberfläche
das nimmt man zur kenntnis sie sind in
reha in eine gut geschützte halle
massivbau der halle aber sie sind
eigentlich ihrem leben zoom an der
erdoberfläche
das ist ein sehr unsicheren absatzlage
aber langfristig ist die ordnung jürgen
und deshalb 19 mal die stabil der
geologische schichten von der natur aus
einen langfristig stabilen und sich los
gewährleistet von natur aus
gewährleistet markus fritschi ist ein
mann der seine worte mit bedacht wählt
die ansicht dass der mensch des menschen
größtes risiko ist und nicht die natur
bald auch dieses kribbeln von
atomgegnern und hält deshalb jeden
donnerstag eine mahnwache gegen das
geplante endlager ab was versprechen sie
sich sowohl das mehl realisiere was
eigentlich da los
wir sind die größte gar nicht um was ich
frage mich wie viel liegt jetzt wieder
aufstehen immer einig müsse tun was ist
das gerade im sand lag ist vor allem
zuerst einmal dass man die haut färbt
stehen das vertrauen in accra ist haben
jetzt sehr groß
wir machen zur 8 es wird wenig
hält man auch anders sehen wir auch
andere stimmen gehört über geologie
wieso machen sie das was sie machen
heraus verantwortung dass man so nicht
unbedingt gern bei sich hat aber mir
gespürt großes verständnis dass man die
umweltschutz hof gab es im land nur
lösen
ich glaube es wichtig die daraus dass
man die aufgabe gelöst wo geologie die
beste voraussetzungen bietet wort
sicherheit am größten ist und ich spüre
viel verständnis von der bevölkerung bis
wieder kritische kreise dass man das an
einem ort zu machen wo es am sichersten
und ich denke das ist der richtige
schritt
das argument dass die aufgabe am
geologisch bästenhardt gelöst werden
muss würde auch der initianten der
mahnwache marian studios ein leuchten
nur habe sie in all den jahren schon zu
oft erlebt dass die argumente
ausgetauscht worden sein
das problem aber sei geblieben was
sollten wir sind akzeptieren wenn geräte
immer alles auch experten für andere
ideen bringen wir immer mehr innere der
jeweils kreisseite wenn der abfall
verbot neue vorgabe zur machen vergessen
dass sich verstehen uns vergessen von
presse das vergessen erfordert einen
langen schlaf wenn die endgültige
abkühlung heute verwendete brennstäbe
wird der mensch wohl nicht mehr erleben
über unvorstellbare zieht drüben
wenn ich mir vorstelle zwei generationen
profitiert ist schon mal vor du sie
generationen zu 33 lang in jener herr
durch die generationen eine baustelle so
lang braucht ist solange nur zum teil
wird aber also teil der cd haltet und
auf die halb radioaktivität aber hoch
marian studios und jörg haase vermuten
dass die nagra nicht alle karten auf den
tisch lege vor allem wenn vor ort
brennstäbe umverpackt würden seien die
risiken höher als bisher angenommen
[Musik]
präsentiert wird die neue professorin
werbeprospekt donnerstag bis verkauf und
die ganzen negativen auswirkungen
sozialer ökonomischer aber auch
sicherheit die werden natürlich
verschwiegen
neben dem weinland das als standort
weniger heimlich zürich nordost heißt
stehen auch jura ost und nördlich lägern
so auswahl
egal wo wir stehen ist es halt auch
also wenn jetzt experte zum schluss
kämpfen und zwar wirklich unabhängig
glaubwürdig könnten schildert dass es da
wirklich die besten könnten sie sich
damit abfinden dass sie absolut ehrlich
klärt sie über weltkrieg fahrer wurden
verschickt und demos bevölkerung bestand
wenn bevölkerung nie verstanden sich als
endlager ruft zwinge ich auch nicht so
dass es mag uhr menschlich sein
schwierige situationen deren folgen erst
in weiter zukunft eintreten zu
verdrängen
und wie überall ist es auch in
beilngries gemeinde nur eine minderheit
die sich aufgrund des geplanten
endlagers heute schon sorgen macht
sorgen und ängste lügt ein sitzgefühl
wir werden irgendwo in der in der
thematik dass die standortgemeinde also
mir hat er ihn ja immer so eine
organisation machen es auch info
veranstaltungen die werte zum teil
besucht
jetzt lege grad unterlagen auf york
geboren wurden im juni stattfinden mehr
handel markiert also labor ich es nicht
wunder wie viel blut dass räume die
unterlagen vorarlberger die nächste
woche nicht sogar über dort wo der
agrarpolitik wird informieren frage
hängt einmal handelskette interessiert
sich camille das märchen geschrieben für
informationen und krümmen sich meine ich
sage namen wie handy informiert der
gemeindeversammlungen im vorjahr mit
handys ohne platt roh mal 14 tage meint
verteilen und schrieb ihn immer wieder
wenn ihr business aber ich zeige ihnen
die kataloge von leisten also da sie
schwarz hat viel glück dass ich mit der
thematik befassen was at rico halt nicht
dazu geäußert dass es in der gemeinde
heiße der widerstand von behördenseite
sei zu gering
die nagra habe im weinland gerade
deshalb leichtes spiel will bei brawn
nicht gelten lassen wir haben sehr viele
vorträge stellt jährige mental sehr
großes grundwasservorkommen will wenn
datang georg tisch ist verheerend
wir können bewirken mit der
regionalkonferenz und mit dem forum opa
- monitore hand dass man vertieft und
des architekten abklärt der abklärung
ist im laufe des nah die ersten
ergebnisse mit den hosen ich als filmen
schon viel bewirkt schon viel ist ihm zu
wenig hier grasen der einst derselben
partei angehörte wie seine
gemeindepräsidentin ist überzeugt dass
mehr möglich wäre
immer mehr leute hätten genug davon dass
über ihre köpfe hinweg entschieden werde
ich fühle mich wie agenturen als als
schwer seine partei svp xi und und hat
glaubt eigentlich dass wir immer mit
nino meter mit bestimmen sondern nebenan
verantworten könnte sich immer einfacher
verantwortung übernehme mache
mitbestimmen wenn wir von managern
verantwortlich wenn ich kann mitreden
und mitbestimmen und darum bin ich dann
mal einig dass das nichts richtige
mittel ist in einem fall wenn wir 1 tor
immerhin mit dem privat wollte sie den
abfall store gegen diesen abfall kämpft
er nun mit allen ihm zur verfügung
stehenden mitteln an
unterstützung erhält er sie plötzlich
von jener seite die er früher
bestenfalls mit argwohn beobachtet hatte
zusammen mit atom gegnern aus der region
erstellt der auf seinem land ein mahnmal
[Musik]
ja wo
die für die ewigkeit das plakat ist ewig
sich eine tätigkeit als endlager
tätigkeit hebelten sie vor 20 jahren
denkt dass sie mal so plakat und ihren
ganz sicher nicht und schon gar nicht
mit so lütz erschaffen nicht so dass
eine schaffen es sehr schnell dass man
jetzt mal was machen hätten wir schon
länger miteinander war dass man jetzt
sagen die anlaufstelle ein routiniert
denkt mit nicht im geringsten
aber das ist ja auch irgendwie die
symbolhaft dass man halt mit einem
bereich zu retten und zu erschaffen und
sammeln und zu spät also untereinander
und gegen andere spieler und und die
entweder jetzt haben wir das talent
gesehen mit einer redlichen etwas wert
wer will ihm nicht beipflichten dass die
wichtigen fragen heutzutage nicht mehr
mit links und rechts beantwortet werden
können
wo aber verläuft die trennlinie zwischen
laien und experten
und wenn ja wen kommt welche aufgabe zu
aufgabe ist der gesellschaft sind als
grundlage zur verfügung stelle um
fungiert die faktische jetzt für den
entscheid modell schafft treffen und wie
wir bei jeder infrastruktur humala kids
natürlich vor ort direkt betroffen wo
frank rieger die für
infrastrukturanlagen den kauf ihres land
bucht wird für seitige aber auch in
einer solidarischen gesellschaft müssten
die einen hin und wieder die lasten
zugunsten aller tragen dafür sollten sie
einen entsprechenden ausgleich erhalten
wenn man hier ist im land der welt die
standortsuche aus wissenschaftlicher
sicht dann ist das ein konsens wo man am
anfang von verfahren sich einige hat
dann kann man auch einen nutzen
ok jetzt die man diskutieren ob jetzt
der beste standort sie ordern oder zwei
fest
danke dann ist der anspruch von
gesellschaften fester standort machen
das ist ein die auf der anderen seite
gibt es infrastruktur bei der
übergeordneten darüber reden was die
wieviel gebäude das in dieburg gebäude
gestaltet sind wie es in der landschaft
nicht geordnet sind
das ist die flexibilität aber wenn es um
sicherheit geht dann sind wir da sich
das land sieht sich herr zeltner genau
starb sie und entscheidungsfaktor und
dann gibt es natürlich wieder fragliche
direkte mitbestimmung
das ist die beste lösung zu finden dabei
einerseits solidarisch zu sein und
andererseits die interessen der
einzelnen zu berücksichtigen den
volkswillen zu akzeptieren jedoch das
wissen der experten anzuerkennen man
könnte es die kernaufgabe unserer zeit
nennen
erst wenn sich der mensch keine dinge
mehr eindruck die ihm dann für immer auf
dem magen liegen ist es vielleicht zeit
nach unkonventionellen lösungen zu
suchen
ja ich habe rücken der experte sieht
sich als nicht machbar
es geht im moment drei jahre zwei
gewählt war grausam verstrahlt sind das
ist sehr mobil und das ich fukushima und
die erhöhte geht immer furchtbar
berichtet geld bezirken rahmen über die
bewohner aber zum gedächtnis ruft der
halter zum radioaktivität so gut die
grüße wie es geht
das koste und zoomen und wenn jetzt die
ganz welt zweimal dennis macht und das
geld sei dass das kann ich sie
vielleicht eine lösung machbar aber
vielleicht sich in seiner fantasie mit
dem jahr zur energiestrategie 2050 hat
das schweizer stimmvolk heute ein klares
bekenntnis zu erneuerbaren energien
abgegeben und außerdem bestimmt dass in
der schweiz keine neuen atomkraftwerke
gebaut werden dürfen
[Musik]